and the spirit award for best director  goes to  chloe joe for nomad land  well thank you so thank you so much  members of film independent  uh i want to thank my fellow nominees  for their beautiful work it's an  honor and i'm so humbled to be in your  company uh  big shout out to team noma land i love  you guys  nancy steve matthew david taylor barry  michelle  everyone said shy pictures you guys rock  thank you for your guidance  for putting up with me and i also i'd  like to take  this opportunity to say thank you to the  independent film community  we wouldn't be here without you um thank  you to the people who are behind all the  mentorship programs all the labs  film festivals everyone works so hard to  support us filmmakers we get to do  what we love and feel like we're part of  a big family because of you so  i want to dedicate this award to you  thank you so much